- Well congrats on season three
of The Masked Singer.
- Ah thank you, thank you so much.
- My family, huge fans of the show.
They totally guess before y'all do.
They're incredible at it.
So what's new this year?
- First of all, it is just such an honor
to be a part of an amazing family show
that, you know, families love it
and my kids love it.
Alexa and Zooey.
They love it.
- What are their names?
- It's so fun to bring the family
together to watch it.
And this season is just bigger and better.
The producers, God bless them.
They just find new ways to reinvent
themselves every year.
But the talent pool is deeper.
There are just more surprising reveals.
It really has evolved.
The show has just gotten better
as it's gone along.
And you know, I'm invested into it
as a fan even if I wasn't on the show.
I just love, it's like America's
guessing game.
- I love a game, so I'm in.
Yeah I love trying to guess.
I'm not as good.
My sister nails it every time.
- Really?
- Yes. I'm horrible.
- You're looking at a guy that's
never got a guess right in three years.
- Yeah I know you say
you're the clueless judge.
- I'm the dumbest judge
on The Masked Singer.